célébrer l'excellence ces étudiants
droits sont majeurs de leur promotion
chaque année la faculté les eaux nord
lors de sa rentrée solennelle pour
montrer également l'émission
l'université et d'une faculté de droit
en particulier et puis
fédérer notre communauté autour de
valeurs communes qui sont celles de
l'université avec sa spécificité qui
l'adossement des formations à la
recherche
une quinzième rentrée de la faculté à la
saveur particulière
l'année scolaire 2020 2021 a été marquée
par des courants distant ciel avec tout
ce travail
je me rends compte que mes efforts sont
récompensés
ça me fait vraiment plaisir tu peux
d'avoir
un prix par rapport à sa malice on s'est
très bien passé de très bons en signant
un très bon enseignement une très bonne
ambiance à lui vécu beaucoup d'entre
aide entre les étudiants et avec cette
pandémie on sait très bien
c'est très bien organisé entre nous
présent dans l'assemblée proches mais
aussi enseignants chercheurs équipes
administratives et partenaires du monde
juridique privée et institutionnelle
cette rentrée était parrainée par les
bâtonniers des barreaux de paris et de
versailles pour recevoir cette activité
du droit de situations d'évolution le
cas de free qui connaissez pas
nécessairement bien je vais essayer de
leur transmettre cet intérêt pour le
droit l'importance du droit dans la
société la question de la de la place de
des relations de apaisé le droit n'est
pas que du conflit n'est pas que de la
justice le droit c'est aussi des
contrats c'est aussi la manière de
traiter des affaires c'est aussi la
manière de régler les problèmes de la
médiation liberté d'expression et
réalités du métier ont été les
principaux sujets évoqués 56 étudiants
ont été récompensés